hello and welcome to this video playing
cast or with black let's see what we get
usually we have this I'm going to play
my Chi Goren because i have had a couple
of games against him every game he got
outplayed and one on time so i'm trying
this again not to lose on time but see
if he places any better now and wins
convincingly maybe i'll use on time
again it was some swindler whatever what
happened here so now the lines no
we played this a million million times
good yeah the setup would be 3f I think
it's very harmless h4 why why is that
even working Bishop g4 okay now maybe
you can play Bishop g5 to avoid them
horn loss okay you just blundered this
pawn so the game just progresses as they
usually progress against this player
some are winning a bone here for not
much so what to do here however this
problem for h5 and Bishop g5 night on
the aid still looks a bit silly so when
I can also take now and play at 5y of
six for that matter and I came don't
like it so much to take it and it should
be okay
to trade rooks am it's always important
it's not totally easy because the b5
porn is still some good week it's not a
totally easy task
Jack Queen a true looks good for c4 I
can still take care because of my back
rank problem so maybe move the Queen
yeah just move the Queen here we need my
Knights somewhere on the queenside that
would be very helpful c4 night night to
see five or something that's difficult
to get
tries to bring the bishop around and
five is not a good idea Bishop g4 we
should be six of this kind of thing
don't know I didn't do that much I'm
trying unite a six and then before as my
idea maybe I should have actually
entered with the Queen the night now had
protected b5 quite well hmm maybe that's
what I should have done also maybe i can
put bring the night over to e7 and then
play at five ok so he allows me to close
it down maybe I could have taken also so
this night should go to e7
preparing at five yeah maybe that is
actually quite ambitious this idea
trying to trap my queen or maybe and I
don't see how that would work
okay on age 6 hmm and g5 is not who I
would like to play maybe after Queen age
six looks dangerous
my nightie area on c7 not doing anything
can I do this here I'm surprised that he
that he allowed this
try to get it to g7 C trying to trick my
queen here I don't see it I don't see it
simply push up the two I can go can go
back again to a one so they I would like
a fire foot probably not going to work
time morning I have to be cautious with
Queenie to a little bit 55 seconds
tween 80 no let's have to avoid it's
probably difficult to win maybe it just
it is somewhat okay for him I can take
that I'm getting nervous here what the
heck check all right worth it I'm an
orphan in on time yeah it was probably
it was difficult to win the game he just
blundered this pawn down when but it's
difficult to win it so closed and he had
those kind of back and forth maneuvers
on my queen it's probably objectively a
draw yeah me I think he tried something
because he felt like he was losing on
time anyway
I probably cannot do much them
objectively speaking yeah okay and it
was some f5 the hindrances but tough
yeah I'm glad to have have won the game
at least I mean I have like out of 7
games I had like six winners and have
minus 2 and so this is h was just a
strange movement yeah it gives away a
poem for for not much but I'd probably
also didn't play it well Queenie 7 with
hindsight probably I should just take on
g3 immediately and this close down the
position and maybe I have f5 now I'm not
sure about it my choice f4 is very
tricky yeah okay this is very comparable
to the game i probably have some extra
extra tempe than comparison so all this
was ok getting the rooks always good
probably around here I'm missing to get
more and the engine wants to go create
choices and I thought he can take here
check you know I saw that I didn't
continue this line here I'm actually
completely safe and I'm picking up all
the pawns okay this was my problem I saw
that my back rank is weakish and then
has stopped okay but this makes Queen a
to Astra very strong move if you cannot
take now I thought he can take if he has
to this is what the engine is giving an
analytic this this and f5 yeah here this
is this is excellent Oh black this is
probably in the moment where I can
really get a big advantage yeah and okay
the way it went I think it's very
difficult to do something I mean maybe
if you have lots of time on your hands
and can
and find a perfect maneuvering but I
don't know not easy at all okay well
thanks for watching